c'était la grande mode dans les années
soixante dix les parents allaient
réinventer l'école primaire elle s
impliqué on allait faire entrer de la
musique de l'art différentes choses pour
rendre l'école différentes pour nos
enfants alors sommes nous en train
d'assister ou retour en force de ces
écoles alternatives
après l'ouverture l'automne dernier de
celle de pointe saint charles
une première en 25 ans à la csdm
d'autres projets sont à l'étude
notamment dans la salle hochelaga
maisonneuve le plateau viré j'en
discuterai dans un instant avec la
présidente de la csdm de même qu'une
maman qui souhaite elle qu'un projet
prenne vie donc d'ici quelques mois
mais d'abord ce reportage d'emilie
dubreuil
on sait que c'est difficile de réussir à
l'épaule dans les 5 pour 1 à 40 % des
livres qui décroche son diplôme d'études
secondaires après 17 ans de collecter et
arrêts ont un peu peur quand on regarde
ces chiffres on veut que nos enfants
près de la nature on veut ramener la
nature dans la classe donc aussi dit
qu'une plus c'est pas 2 durant une
partie de l'enseignement on va pas à
l'extérieur de la salle de classe on va
voir en action en mouvement
oh
l'école alternative connaît ses heures
de gloire au québec en même temps que
les pattes d'éléphant entre 1974 et 1984
une vingtaine d'écoles primaires aux
pédagogies ouvertes vont voir le jour
apprentissage par projet par le jeu une
réaction en quelque sorte à l'école
traditionnelle et son enseignement
magistral et puis comme les pattes
d'éléphant la mode des écoles
alternatives à s'estomper
or depuis deux ans l'école alternative
est de nouveau dans le vent est-ce que
ça c'est des tomates et cette cour
d'école où les enfants font du jardinage
on est la manifestation concrète c'est
la première école alternative à la
commission scolaire de montréal à ouvrir
en 25 ans une dizaine de projets sont en
gestation un peu partout au québec
c'est beaucoup lorsqu'on considère qu'il
n'y a que trente et une école
alternative publique au québec
une nouvelle explosion de demander et
qui sont un peu nouvelle un peu
différente
contact avec la nature on leur prouve
ici à charles lemoyne qui on le retrouve
dans d'autres projets la commission
scolaire de montréal et ailleurs au
québec fois ci c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est en train de se passer
c'est évident mais pourquoi ses parents
et son style le besoin de réinventer
l'école des écoles vertes
de surcroît
comment on essaye de vivre le mieux
possible notre urbanisme on déménage
tous puis on s'en va en banlieue où est
ce qu'on se dit non on va vivre en ville
mais le mieux possible
professeur à l'université de montréal en
psychoéducation mélanie paré est aussi
la mère de deux jeunes garçons et elle
milite pour l'ouverture d'une école
nature d'enlever la salle 300 parents du
quartier sont d'accord avec ce projet on
parle beaucoup de super activités et on
parle beaucoup des garçons à l'école on
parle beaucoup de de rendre l'enfant
accepte sans que ça quitte les murs de
la classe puisque pour embarrasser
questionnaire
ses parents du mile end pilote aussi un
projet d'école verte
ce parc urbain secrète en quelque sorte
la salle de classe de leurs enfants
comme tous les parents derrière les
projets d'école d'alternative ils se
veulent avant tout disponible car
l'ingrédient de base c'est l'engagement
des parents comme ce qu'on peut donner
ce qu'on a donné nos patients on peut
on peut on accède à la classe on peut
rentrer on peut aider le professeur pour
des activités on peut on peut créer une
petite activité nous mêmes sur toute
cette génération de parents connaît
moins le 9 à 5
il ya de plus en plus de travailleurs
autonomes on a des horaires de plus en
plus fragmenté et si ça fait pas en
sorte qu' on est capable on pourrait on
souhaiterait une rencontre est avec nos
enfants puis avec leur vie scolaire à
l'intérieur de la grille horaire de
l'école à pointe-saint-charles le volet
alternatif va s'agrandir de deux
nouvelles classes l'an prochain
en tout c'est déjà une centaine
d'enfants de plus dans l'école des
enfants de la classe moyenne qui serait
probablement aller ailleurs un ajout
positif donc dans cette école
défavorisée où il ne manque pas de place
mais dans certaines écoles c'est le
contraire ça déborde à cause du
baby-boom là l'engouement pour l'école
alternative n'est qu'on toujours
bienvenu dans le mile end
le projet de l'école des possibles
piloté par ses parents auraient pu voir
le jour dès la rentrée avec deux classes
pilotes à l'école lambert closse mais
l'idée a suscité une vive opposition de
la part des autres parents en ces temps
de mekin vont proposer cette classe et
en septembre de messages neuf classes si
on acceptait les deux les codes dans le
même bâtiment
il ya quelque chose qui devrait sortir
dans rosemont petite patrie la csdm a
investi près de 2 millions $ pour
rénover un immeuble excédentaire pour
accueillir une nouvelle école
alternative de 200 places plutôt
favorable au projet du genre la csdm se
trouve coincé entre l'arbre et les
corses
jamais on mettra en péril l'école
régulière au profit du démarrage de
nouveaux projets c'est pas possible
avec moi pour poursuivre la discussion
la réflexion sur les écoles alternatives
catherine harel bourdon vous la
connaissez président de la commission
scolaire de montréal et marine chapin
vous est l'instigatrice d'un projet dont
émilie viennent parler dans le bar
hélène l'école des possibles mais
d'abord madame harel bourdon est ce que
cette poussée vous confirmer qu'il ya
une nouvelle mode là mais on sent très
bien qu'elle ait parents veulent
s'investir dans l'éducation de leurs
enfants de toutes sortes de façons dans
des projets alternatifs dans les projets
pédagogiques particuliers
je sais pas je suis pas sociologue je
sais pas si c'est dû au fait que
maintenant les deux parents sont très
investies dans l'éducation des enfants
que beaucoup de parents qui ont un peu
plus de temps ou qui ont des horaires
atypiques ou encore le fait que
maintenant il ya souvent le congé de
maternité de paternité qui est pris par
les deux parents mais on sent qu une
volonté autant dans les écoles
alternatives que dans d'autres types
d'écoles régulière en scène une
implication des parents puis une volonté
avez vous de la place pendant marais le
bourdon pour combien il ya de demandes
actuellement sur votre table mais en
fait nous on est on a une demande
officielle qui est l'école des
postillons nos deux demandes en
gestation nhk maisonneuve et dans
villeray où on n'a pas eu de dépôt final
de ces paroles nous c'est sûr qu'on doit
d'abord regardé l'aise parce qu'on a la
halle le nombre d'élèves qu'on a dans
chacun des quartiers quand c'est
possible de le faire on le fait dans le
chaos à la fin du reportage on parlait
petite patrie dans le code patrie on
était dans une relocalisation d'élèves
du secondaire là l'école alternative
secondaire le vitrail et les parents et
le personnel de l'école nous ont
demandés on aimerait se faire une école
primaire et secondaire aviv son ensemble
primaires et secondaires à l'internet
c'est fait c'est pour ça qu'on est allé
de l'avant avec le projet de la rue
boyer qui demandent des investissements
mais en fait on utilise un immeuble qui
nous appartenait à vraiment faire le
trimestre
et les études montrent que les enfants
parce que la question qui se pose et je
vais vous passez la parole madame chopin
c'est ce que les enfants qui passent à
travers une formation dans une école
alternative réussissent aussi bien au
secondaire un bon madame harel d'ensuite
par chopin mais en fait moi j'ai
l'impression que quand on passe au
secondaire on peut tout aussi bien
réussir c'est l'investissement le temps
le soutien du personnel de l'école
soutien des parents qui est très
important dans un volet alternatif faut
comprendre que nous on est ouvert mais
que c'est sûr qu'on doit d'abord
répondre aux besoins des communautés de
chaque quartier parce que madame chopin
votre projet dans le mile end l'école
des possibles donc vient heurter un peu
ceux qui disent nous on n'a pas cette
place nous même pour l'école entre
guillemets traditionnel tout à fait oui
et alors est ce que vous voyez une issue
de l'espace pour les deux mais en fait
ce qu'on a sur papier c'est que il ya
une école de quartier à 50 % de capacité
d'accueil d'élèves
évidemment on est dans un boom
démographique ce boom démographique
l'unedic pas aussi ses parents la veille
de l'école régulière ou alternative est
en fait nous notre projet a démarré en
fait simplement parce que on est des
parents qui souhaitent l alternatif on a
essayé plusieurs écoles alternatives on
a vécu plusieurs refus et on s'est
retrouvé dans une école régulière mais
plusieurs parents l'année dernière on
était la moitié de la classe qui avait
tout essayé d école alternative donc
c'est un petit peu on se retrouve dans
des écoles régulières et comme on sait
que les projets alternatifs parts des
parents mais c'est là on s'est dit on
n'a pas le choix quelque part si on veut
pouvoir offrir ce choix là nos enfants
faut qu'on parte un projet et on a vu
l'engouement fait dans notre quartier
pour pour ce genre d' approche
pédagogique en quoi madame chopin là je
suis comme un exercice à l'école pages à
vous demander ça ne me résumer en
quelques secondes
en quoi votre projet et meilleure ou
différents pour vos enfants de l'école
traditionnelle
je vous dis tout est différent et en
fait notre projet et tactiques comme
d'autres écoles vers la nature on veut
des apprentissages à l'extérieur on veut
reconnecter nos enfants
avec la nature et on veut justement en
fait c'est vraiment une différence
on veut pouvoir s'impliquer on veut une
approche collaborative qu'il ya moins de
poids sur l'enseignant que c'est une
collaboration c'est l'enfance et le
parent c'est l'enseignant si la
direction si le service de garde très
bien madame harel bourdon donc en
conclusion il y a de la place pour les
deux les deux formes d'éducation aux
primaires mais je dois faire juste
mentionné que dans le cas de l'école des
possibles si c'est pas possible à
lambert closse on ne va pas obliger la
communauté à recevoir un autre projet
faut bien comprendre qu on a fait un
sondage on est en train d'analyser les
résultats du sondage
puis après ça on va trouver des
solutions avec les gens autant l'école
des possibles que les gens et lambert
closse mais on n'imposera pas un projet
dans une école il faut vraiment le
partir avec les parents qui voir qu'est
ce qui est possible dans cette
communauté il faut qu'un faux clé les
autres s'entendent également madame
harel board on vous a vu un peu plus tôt
dans le reportage sur les compressions à
venir vous êtes très craintive à deux
jours du budget du québec
là les services aux élèves sont vraiment
touché vous dites là soyons clairs oui
les services aux élèves sont touchées en
fait dans notre plan de redressement
financier des dernières années on a fait
des gros efforts pour aller faire des
compressions sûr du soutien
administratif ceux d'autres types de
postes et là on est rendu à l'étape où
neuro nécessairement un impact dans les
milieux sur les services aux élèves
mais donc en tant qu'un le réflexe de
dire que la grosse commission scolaire
de montréal on pourrait couper dans
l'administratif et non pas dans le
service aux élèves vous répondez quoi
mais c'est qu'on le fait en a coûté 191
poste en fait on est rendu en bas de 4 %
de frais administratifs pour une
institution publique comme la nôtre et
qui gère le milieu scolaire 212 mille
élèves avec le transport les services
alimentaires les ressources matérielles
27 agrandissement d'école parce qu on
est en augmentation du nombre d'élèves
une immigration importante donc des
cours de francisation pour les plus
jeunes mais aussi pour les parents donc
c'est un défi colossal est ce qu'on dit
au gouvernement du québec c'est étant
donné tous ses besoins criants
étant donné tous les efforts qu'on a
faits on pense que les compressions
supplémentaires vont nécessairement
avoir un impact dans nos milieux
chez nos élèves on voit sur le terrain
va souffler sur le terrain des exemples
concrets quand il y en aura d'autres
marines de chacun on vous souhaite votre
école donc si s'il ya de la place et
dans lambert classé sinon ailleurs mais
on va suivre ça dans la moyenne ou
ailleurs oui madame harel bourdon merci
d'avoir été avec nous est intéressant de
voir que cette mode lent tout cas est
l'eau à nouveau au québec qu'à montréal
en particulier de ces projets éducatifs
différents puis un bébé boom il ya des
enfants qui n'ont presque jamais eu mais
la merci beaucoup merci au revoir